And the answer should look like this. You've got
your opening em tag, the phrase HTML is reasonably
straightforward, and then the closing em tag. And, our
b tags are still where we left them. Hopefully
you managed to figure this out that HTML tags
can be nested just fine and the, the whole
phrase is in italics because the whole phrase is
surrounded by these tags. And just the words reasonably straightforward
are in bold because those are just the
words that are surrounded by the b tags. Let's
experiment with that in the editor a little bit
here. So I'm going to take the closing em tag
off here and put it on the back. And if we update this, we can see that the
whole phrase learn to love HTML is in italics,
and that's what we just saw on the quiz.